So we are now post midterm.
We've gotten past the midterm,
which is excellent.
And what I want--the lecture
I'm going to give today is
actually titled "Heroes and
Villains,"
and I'm going to explain what
that means in just a few
minutes.
I'm going to segue,
so I'm just touching on one or
two of the things that I talked
about at the end of the last
lecture,
segueing right in to this
lecture.
And hopefully you remember that
right before the midterm,
the last lecture I gave,
I was talking about the process
of organizing a war.
And I talked about some of the
problems that the Continental
Congress had in dealing with the
Continental Army,
and I at least referred to some
of the ways in which these
problems hinted at larger
problems with unity between the
newly created American states.
So for example,
I talked about regionalism,
and I talked about some of the
ways in which regionalism
complicated the task of
organizing the Continental Army,
for example things like
considering how to balance
positions of military command
between Northerners and
Southerners,
or getting units from one
region of the country to deal
with units from another region
of the country,
or getting soldiers from
different regions as well as
individual soldiers to agree to
sacrifice for the common good
throughout the entire
confederation of states instead
of thinking about their own
state or their own locality
above all else.
And I also talked about a
related problem,
and I called that the problem
of localism,
and I talked about how a
localized view of the world,
or certainly a localized view
of the new states,
worked against centralized
control.
So localities of all sorts had
difficulty surrendering local
control to some kind of a
central organization like the
Continental Congress,
which obviously had to equip
the army,
and thus that raised all kinds
of other complications and
problems.
Each state wanted to maintain
control, for example,
of its own militia.
And then finally,
at the very end of the lecture
I mentioned that many people who
would end up being strong
nationalists in the 1780s and in
the 1790s--
people who were going to end up
being at the forefront of the
movement to strengthen the
Articles of Confederation--
many of these people gained
their political beliefs and the
need for some kind of a stronger
centralized national government
from their experiences during
the Revolution,
from their experiences with
what often felt like what
Alexander Hamilton called an
imbecilic centralized
government.
That was his word that he
applied to the Continental
Congress, "imbecilic."
So basically,
looking at the army and then
looking at Congress,
we see regionalism and localism
both working against centralized
control and coordination.
We see a lack of precedent for
centralized governance of this
kind, which led to some
confusion.
And certainly that made it
possible for any important
decision that had to do with
centralized power having
seemingly enough importance to
make it earth-shaking--
and thus seemingly trivial
things ended up seeming to have
huge importance because they
might set a precedent,
again all of this working
against effectiveness.
So all of these things
complicated the creation not
just of a Continental Army,
but also of first,
colonial unity,
and then American unity and--
as we're going to see in weeks
to come--
ultimately constitutional unity.
And we're going to see this
sort of concern and confusion
and these complications of
centralized power coming up
again and again this semester,
particularly at the beginning
of April when we begin to talk
about the Articles of
Confederation and people really
debating about what's the best
form of government for these new
states to unite under.
So these ideas--things like
regionalism and things like
localism and how they
complicated the army,
and also centralized
power--those things are actually
going to come up in today's
lecture which,
as I said, I titled
"Heroes and Villains."
And what I'm really going to be
doing in today's lecture--It's a
different kind of lecture from
ones that I've given before.
Happily for you,
it's a lecture that will
probably require you to take
less notes than you typically
take in lecture for this course,
because what I'm going to do is
kind of use a case study to look
up close at just a handful of
people and a series of events as
a way of exploring some of the
ideas that we've been talking
about generally--
ideas about the Congress,
ideas about the army,
and how they actually played
out in a few individual lives.
So what we're going to see in
the course of today's lecture,
which in a way is one big
story, is some of the
complications inherent in how
the Continental Congress handled
the Continental Army.
We're going to see a very
specific example of that.
We're going to see regionalism
making trouble in the
Continental Army.
We're going to see how serving
in the army affected--in the
case of today's lecture--several
people's lives in a really
direct way.
And then on a broader scale,
by looking at this one story--
which is intertwined with the
actions of the Continental Army
and what it meant to this
handful of lives--
we're also going to see some
broader truths about American
society at the time.
So we're going to see for
example how the army was an
outlet for personal ambition,
how people maybe tried to use
service in the army as a way to
promote themselves,
something that I've mentioned
before.
We're going to see how living
at a time of war opened paths
for people that might not
otherwise have existed.
We're going to see the
sometimes slippery status of
women during a time of war,
and we're going to see how many
Americans still revered some
British cultural ideals even in
the midst of war against
Britain.
And the story that I'm going to
use today,
the sort of case study that's
going to help us delve into all
of these things,
is the story of Benedict
Arnold, Peggy Shippen Arnold,
and John Andre.
All of these people--All three
of these people,
in one way or another,
attempted to use the war and
its armies to make,
or I guess maybe more
accurately to unmake,
themselves and their
reputations.
In one way or another,
all of them were trying to
better themselves through the
opportunities of warfare.
Now before we launch into that
case study,
I just want to talk for a
moment about why warfare created
such opportunities for
potentially raising a person's
social status,
and thus why some people were
actually eager for war.
Now in some of the early
lectures for this course,
I discussed social status in
the colonies and I talked a
little bit about how society in
the colonies,
while it certainly did have an
elite sort of gentlemanly rank
of people,
that overall American society
tended to be more middling than
English society,
which did have an entrenched
aristocratic class.
In America, if you wanted to
have gentlemanly status--
and in a sense it was more
difficult to be born into it in
the way that you could have in a
European nation--
there were actually a limited
number of pathways that were
open to you to achieve that kind
of a status.
Basically, there were a handful
of professions that were assumed
in this period to be
gentlemanly.
These included medicine,
the law, the ministry,
the church, perhaps being a
merchant that was wealthy enough
that you didn't seem to be
grubbing for money--
that you seemed to be living
happily off of your vast sums of
money,
maybe someone who owned a
really sizable plantation,
or serving as an officer in an
army.
And I was sort of unsure what
to do with college professors,
near and dear to my heart.
I decided I would not
officially put them on the list,
although many college
professors in this period would
have been in the clergy,
certainly some of them would
have been lawyers,
so I think they would have
generally fallen into the
gentlemanly ranks,
but I'm being unbiased here so
I'm leaving college professors
over here somewhere.
Okay.
So of all of those positions
that I've just named,
being a military officer,
serving as an officer during--
in an army but particularly
during a time of war,
offered the greatest chance for
instant glory,
instant status,
instant rank through bravery
and displays of valor on the
battlefield.
For the very ambitious or for
people who had a problematic
social rank for one reason or
another,
a war could be a great
opportunity for you to improve
your place in the world,
particularly in a place like
America.
And one extreme example of this
is actually Alexander Hamilton,
who was born illegitimate in
the West Indies--
and it's really clear from the
absolute first letter of his
that we know of,
which was written when he was
fourteen years old,
that he absolutely thought that
his only ticket off of the
island of St.
Croix was through military
glory in a war.
That was really the way that he
saw that he was going to make
something of himself,
get himself off of St.
Croix, earn a name,
get status, get reputation,
and start the process of making
something of himself in the
world.
So as he says in this letter,
and it's written when he's
fourteen, "my Ambition is
prevalent....
I wish there was a War."
Okay.
[laughs]
As a historian,
you're so happy--
again, I said this before--when
your historical subjects say the
thing you want them to say that
you can then quote forever
after.
'Hi.
I am ambitious and I want a war
so I can promote myself.'
Thank you, Alexander Hamilton,
very much.
Okay.
Now in a sense Hamilton was
extreme,
because he was very
underprivileged,
he was extremely ambitious and
very determined,
but in a sense his entire
generation of young men saw the
Revolution as a chance for
glory,
status, rank, self-promotion.
And I talked about a similar
idea last week when I mentioned
that there were a number of
Europeans who came to America
during the Revolution,
sometimes because they figured
that they could probably impress
Americans,
or certainly impress the
Continental Congress with their
experience in formal European
warfare,
and then they could get a
position as an officer easier
than they might have been able
to obtain it or purchase it back
home,
and--so that there were a
number of Europeans coming to
this country for that purpose.
And I mentioned at the time
that actually Hamilton,
trying to do something really
similar,
said that watching these
Europeans come and get promoted
by the Congress above his head
gave him what he called
"pigmy-feelings,"
made him feel really puny,
really small in comparison with
these sort of grand Europeans
coming and sort of getting
everything that he wanted and he
wasn't getting because he was
just a puny,
little American.
So in a sense,
in a world where there were a
limited number of pathways to
gentlemanly status,
serving as an officer during a
time of war could be kind of an
escalator of rank,
offering the chance to get
ahead at a rapid pace.
So being an officer in the
Continental Army could have
seemed particularly attractive
to highly ambitious men who were
looking for some kind of a big
chance,
and Benedict Arnold was one of
those men.
Now I think when most Americans
think about the American
Revolution--And I remember I
started out this course sort of
talking about the same idea.
I assumed that maybe people
know Washington led the army,
that Paul Revere rode around on
a horse saying something about
the British,
that Jefferson had something to
do with the Declaration of
Independence,
and I'll add to that list,
most people know Benedict
Arnold was a traitor.
They don't know why,
they don't know how,
but you assume the name
Benedict Arnold goes along with
the word "traitor."
John Adams was pretty much
right on the money when he
predicted how future generations
were going to see the American
Revolution,
and it's right in line with
what I just said.
And he actually wrote in 1790
to Benjamin Rush,
"The History of our
Revolution will be one continued
lie from one end to the other.
The essence of the whole will
be that Dr. Franklin's
electrical Rod smote the Earth
and out sprung General
Washington.
[laughter]
That Franklin electrified him
with his Rod--
[laughs]
and henceforth these two
conducted all the Policy,
Negotiations,
Legislatures and War."
Okay.
So Adams is actually probably
coming pretty close to reality.
People are going to look back
and they're going to say,
'Yeah, yeah.
Franklin, Washington,
and the war.
That was the Revolution.'
Now I always--I knew that quote.
I've known it for a long time.
I love that quote,
which is why I found a reason
to sort of wind it into today's
lecture,
but when I went back to look it
up today,
for the first time I actually
read the whole letter that it
comes from.
And I found another sentence
which I actually hadn't focused
on before,
and it made me so happy that I
offer it to you,
even though it isn't directly
related to the point I'm making,
but I kind of couldn't believe
he wrote it in his letter.
So he offers that quote and
then he adds and says,
"If this Letter should be
preserved and read an hundred
years hence--".
Okay.
First of all,
I love the fact that that comes
up in his mind.
Well, a hundred years from now
when people are reading my
letter,
"if this letter should be
preserved and read an hundred
years hence,
the Reader will say,
'the envy of this John Adams
could not bear to think of the
Truth!'"
So in other words,
a hundred years from now if
people read this letter they're
going to say,
'Yeah.
Well, the fact is Adams knew he
wouldn't be remembered.
He doesn't deserve to be
remembered anyway.'
So it's like first there's the
letter where he's like:
'oh,
no one's going to know the
truth about the Revolution and
they're never going to give me
any credit.
[laughter]
I love the weird self-awareness
of John Adams.
I just--I couldn't believe that
he added that into the letter.
So anyway, I think he certainly
knew what he was talking about
when he talked about the weird,
general sort of hero-way in
which people were going to be
thinking about the American
Revolution.
So many Americans know
certainly Benedict Arnold equals
traitor.
Obviously, it's--I'm going to
be talking about it today--
his story is a lot more complex
than that,
and it's mixed in with these
other two stories,
that of Peggy Shippen,
who eventually becomes his
wife,
and John Andre who is a young
British officer.
Now Arnold started out life in
many ways a sort of typical
member of a modest,
respectable family,
and at the opening of the
American Revolution he was a
book-seller and a pharmacist,
or what they would have called
a druggist,
in New Haven, Connecticut.
So he's a local boy,
Benedict Arnold.
He was struggling to better
himself.
How many of you knew actually
that Benedict Arnold was a local
guy?
A couple people did.
That was another one of those
things that--I never know when I
say something about New Haven.
Is it like, 'We all know this
about New Haven,
Professor Freeman.
You are the clueless person.'
[laughter]
So anyway, he was a local boy.
So book-seller,
druggist, New Haven local boy
struggling to better himself,
and part of the way in which
he's struggling to better
himself is to certainly display
himself to the world as someone
who's really up and coming.
So among the things that he was
doing was,
he apparently was building an
enormous mansion for himself on
Water Street,
wearing very expensive
clothing, taking big risks in
business to try and get himself
ahead quickly.
He was also a captain in the
local New Haven militia and so
he was really active drilling at
the opening of the war.
Now when gunplay broke out at
Lexington and Concord,
the New Haven town meeting
apparently decided that they
wanted to maintain neutrality,
which in and of itself was kind
of interesting.
Right?
'Uh oh.
Something bad's happening.
I think for now we want to be
neutral.'
Connecticut's always a very
conservative place so this is
yet another conservative moment
in Connecticut's history.
So they form a committee--The
town meeting forms a committee
to preserve neutrality in New
Haven.
Arnold was not really excited
about this concept of
neutrality,
so apparently he stormed in to
this neutrality committee,
demanded the keys to the
ammunition shed,
and when his superior in the
Connecticut militia told him the
town had legally voted for
neutrality,
Arnold threatened to break down
the ammunition shed door with
his men if they didn't hand over
the keys so he could get
ammunition and take his men and
do something.
And the committee released the
keys and Arnold took them and
armed his men,
and ultimately he and his
militia unit joined the
Continental Army in
Massachusetts.
So this is someone who clearly
is eager to fight.
Right?
He sort of forced his way in.
So he ends up in Massachusetts
with his men.
He's soon promoted to be a
colonel by the Massachusetts
Committee of Safety,
which assigned him to be part
of a group that was going to go
help capture Fort Ticonderoga
and he was--
Arnold was part of that
successful effort in May of
1775.
And by October of 1776,
he was a brigadier general.
Now at this point the very
hierarchical system of military
rank that Arnold was using to
try and raise himself in the
world began to work against him,
because a number of his equals
were promoted to major general,
but Arnold wasn't.
And as I'm going to explain in
a moment,
the reason why he didn't get a
promotion has more to do with
things like regionalism and fear
of centralized authority than it
actually does have anything to
do with Arnold specifically.
So basically,
many of the more radical
members of the Continental
Congress at this time were
afraid that if everyone was
promoted in the Continental Army
just according to seniority of
rank that the army would get
detached from the legislature
and then it would be seniority
and not Congress that would be
determining promotions,
so Congress might end up being
powerless over the army.
And so the result that they
feared would be maybe a military
dictatorship,
an aristocracy based on high
military rank--
that somehow or other,
if the army had control of
promotion everything was going
to spin out of control and
Congress would have no power.
So, afraid of this,
Congress debated and ultimately
decided that officers should be
appointed not just according to
seniority,
but almost more important,
on the basis of balancing out
the numbers of officers from
different states.
Okay.
So they figure we're going to
have regional balance.
We're going to maintain control
of the promotion process and
maintain regional balance in the
numbers of officers.
So essentially in the interest
of preserving a national
confederation of some kind,
regional balance in the
military was given priority.
As Washington--George
Washington explained to Arnold
when Arnold was denied his
promotion,
"as Connecticut had
already two major-generals,
it was their full share."
Okay.
That's got to be really sour
grapes, like 'What?
[laughs]
Connecticut doesn't deserve any
more major generals so I don't
get a promotion?'
"I confess this is a
strange mode of reasoning;
but it may serve to show you,
that the promotion,
that was due to your seniority,
was not overlooked for want of
merit in you."
So he's trying to make Arnold
feel better.
'Well, you actually--I know you
deserved it but I'm sorry.
You really can't have it,
because Connecticut doesn't get
any more for a while.'
Okay.
Arnold did not get his
promotion, did not get it for
want of merit.
This did not make him happy.
Washington's trying to explain
that there are larger principles
at play,
principles that show how
fearful people were of
centralized power in any form,
and in this case they're afraid
of some kind of powerful
standing army,
and they're using regional
balance as a priority to sort of
balance out fears of centralized
power wherever they're afraid
it's going to crop up.
As one congressman wrote at the
time,
Arnold's promotion was blocked
because it raised,
quote, "a question of
monarchical or republican
principles at a most crucial
time."
So you could see even this one
guy's promotion is being tied
into these much larger fears and
ideas.
Congress felt compelled to
establish its promotion policy
based on fears of an independent
standing army that might take
power for itself.
They're trying to keep control
of military promotion--
so here you see fear of a
standing army,
fear of centralized power and
regionalism all stirred up and
all at play in full force.
Now luckily for Arnold at this
point, there was a military
action in Connecticut.
Arnold proved himself
militarily--yet again he ends up
getting promoted to major
general--
but now his rank is beneath
those who had been his equals
before.
Right?
They had been promoted ahead of
him so they still have seniority
over him.
Arnold really wants equal rank,
equal seniority with the men he
had formerly been equal to.
He also felt that Congress owed
him money because he had been
using his personal funds to
supply his troops,
and obviously he's already
living well beyond his means,
so this question of whether or
not he's actually owed money by
Congress and whether or not
Congress is actually going to
pay him back--
for him, that's a serious
question.
The more that Arnold demanded
that he be promoted to the level
of his former equals,
the stronger Congress dug in
its heels and refused to comply,
so that the whole idea clearly
is becoming now a matter of
principle in which the honor and
authority of the Continental
Congress is at stake now in
addition to whatever larger
issues are at play.
And this might sound a little
familiar if you think back to
some of the logic deployed by
the British Parliament as
problems were growing out of
questions of taxation.
In addition to all of the
larger problems and concerns
mixed up in that question,
part of what was at play was
that Parliament ultimately,
at some point down the road of
that controversy,
didn't want to lose face by
seeming to surrender the issue
to its colonies.
So the honor of Parliament is
involved in that issue,
here the honor of the
Continental Congress.
They feel like that's at issue
and they can't just back down
because Arnold is being really
persistent about what he wants.
As South Carolina Congressman
Henry Laurens put it at the
time,
his colleagues' behavior in
Congress was,
quote, "disgusting."
Arnold was refused "not
because he was deficient in
merit or that his demand was not
well founded but because he
asked for it &
that granting at such
insistence would be derogatory
to the honour of Congress."
Now that's Laurens' point of
view.
Another congressman with
different politics and another
point of view came up with a
whole different way of looking
at this whole controversy--
drew very different
conclusions--and said that
denying Arnold his promotion was
a triumph of republican
principles.
Military rank would stay in
control of the legislature;
the army wouldn't become
independent and aristocratic.
So you can see even again
something that is seemingly not
that important,
which is the promotion of one
guy, stirs up all of these
larger issues for all kinds of
people in different ways.
People aren't even united about
what it means.
Now it was at roughly this
moment--
when Arnold is frustrated--he
wants promotion--
he doesn't see a way to get
it--he keeps getting turned
down--
he feels like he's owed money
in some way--
he just feels basically stymied
in every way--
his reputation now he also
feels is being attacked simply
because he's asking for
promotion--
this is roughly the time when
he met Peggy Shippen,
who was the daughter of a
wealthy merchant in
Philadelphia.
Now the Shippens,
along with any number of
Philadelphia's other sort of
best families,
mingled freely with British
officers when the British were
in occupation of Philadelphia--
when the British were not
there, mingled freely with
American officers.
When the British had possession
of Philadelphia apparently there
were elaborate dances and great
sorts of theatrical productions.
It was a grand social scene
when the British were there.
When the British were not
there, Americans also had
entertainments.
They weren't quite as
extravagant, but still enough to
encourage the participation of
all of the best families of
Philadelphia.
Peggy Shippen was certainly in
the midst of all of this
socializing,
enjoying whatever socializing
was going on with whatever
group,
and apparently she was very
popular.
She was sort of the literal
belle of the ball,
one of the more attractive and
noteworthy young women in
Philadelphia's social scene at
that time.
Now this suggests a few things
about Peggy Shippen,
one or two of which are
significant for our story here.
For one obvious thing,
it suggests that she certainly
was dressed at the height of
fashion,
that she was skilled at
flirtation,
that she was aggressive in
social circles,
but what that adds up to as far
as our story is concerned,
is that she was displaying
ambition on one of the few
stages where women could display
open ambition,
and that's social events,
social functions,
in a sense the private world.
But certainly on the social
stage,
that's a place where women
could successfully display and
exercise ambition,
and it certainly suggests that
Peggy Shippen was perfectly
comfortable doing that on the
social scene of Philadelphia.
So Peggy married Benedict
Arnold in April of 1779.
He already was someone who was
spending extravagantly.
This just encouraged him to
increase his spending,
because now he had a wife to
spend on, in addition to
whatever he was spending on
himself.
And it was shortly after his
marriage,
when he still remained
frustrated in his military
hopes,
his expenses are rising and
rising all the time,
this is the moment where he
began to ponder the possibility
of aiding the British.
And apparently in his mind he
justified his actions by
assuming the British were
inevitably going to win anyway,
that the British--that the
likelihood that the colonies
were going to be victorious
against the empire,
in his mind, is unlikely.
So given that the British are
inevitably going to win,
his helping them win the war is
going to end bloodshed as
quickly as possible,
so he's doing a good thing by
somehow helping the British.
Now clearly that's a sort of
self-serving way of looking at
it.
He has other motives too,
but that was part of his logic.
So in May of 1779,
he and Peggy decided to ask a
local man in Philadelphia who
they knew had Loyalist
sympathies and who was a poet to
act as a go-between with the
British so they could at least
open a conversation with them.
And this man,
whose name was Joseph
Stansbury, later described
Arnold's invitation.
He described what Arnold said
to him at this moment:
"General Arnold sent for
me and,
after some general
conversation,
opened his political sentiments
respecting the war carrying on
between Great Britain and
America,
declaring his abhorrence of a
separation of the latter from
the former as a measure that
would be ruinous to both.
General Arnold then
communicated to me,
under a solemn obligation of
secrecy,
his intention of offering his
services to the
Commander-in-Chief of the
British forces in any way that
would most effectually restore
the former government and
destroy the [then]
usurped authority of Congress,
either by immediately joining
the British Army or cooperating
on some concerted plan with Sir
Henry Clinton"--
(who is the British commander
in chief).
Yeah.
That's quite some conversation
there.
Now the person who ultimately
ended up facilitating
communication between Arnold and
Sir Henry Clinton was a young
British officer named Major John
Andre,
who was a sort of favorite of
Henry Clinton,
was sort of his right-hand man.
Apparently, Peggy Shippen knew
him.
They had met when the British
had been in Philadelphia,
and in fact they'd been a
little bit flirtatious when the
British were in Philadelphia,
so they knew each other.
To most people who knew
Andre--and as we're going to see
later on in this story,
particularly to
Americans--Andre was the very
ideal of a gentleman.
He was charming.
He was well educated.
He wrote poetry.
He wrote plays.
He was flirtatious.
He drew portraits to amuse the
ladies and his fellow officers.
He's supposedly very
good-looking.
So basically in a sense,
Andre is sort of this
gentlemanly ideal,
and then he's also this gallant
soldier,
so you add it all up and it's
just a package of sort of
"ideal gentleman."
Like Arnold,
Andre had used the army as a
way to better his station,
although his station was
already somewhat elevated.
So Andre's father was a wealthy
merchant.
Andre thought that trade was a
little bit disreputable so he
decided that the army was a
better way for him to advance
himself,
exercise his ambition,
and achieve fame and glory,
again not that unlike Arnold.
So Andre ends up being at the
center of Arnold's plans with
the British,
and basically the plan was the
Arnolds would send messages to
the British,
but they would be written by
Peggy Arnold and then sent to
Andre through Joseph Stansbury
who would pick up the letters
and deliver them,
crossing back and forth between
American and British lines,
and then Andre could go on and
speak to Henry Clinton himself.
Now Stansbury,
hoping to make things a little
less risky for himself,
got another poet that he knew
behind British lines to carry
the messages from his hand to
Andre's hand.
So Benedict Arnold's
negotiations with the British
would be written out by Peggy;
she'd give her letters to
Stansbury;
Stansbury would give them to
another poet;
the poet would give them to
Andre;
Andre would take them to
Clinton.
Okay.
That's a long chain of people,
but what's really interesting
about that chain of people is
that when you think of the
pieces and the assumptions
underlying the pieces,
it revealed a lot about society
and some of its assumptions at
the time.
It was actually Andre who
suggested that the letters
should at least seem to be
written by Peggy Arnold and
addressed to Andre,
because Andre knew that
something written by a woman
would never be assumed to have
anything to do with politics or
war.
A letter from a woman is going
to assume to be private and
personal.
Women were basically a
nonentity in public life,
they didn't exist as public
figures,
so, as Andre explained in a
note to the Arnolds,
"The Lady,"
meaning Peggy,
"might write to me...
This will come by a flag of
truce, every messenger remaining
ignorant of what they are
charged with."
These will seem like private
letters.
They can kind of write in code.
It'll come from a woman.
No one will know what they are,
and under a flag of truce,
messengers will help deliver
these messages and no one will
know what they are,
because they're written by a
woman.
So their letters to each other
could seem to talk about things
like parties and dances and what
Andre termed "other
nonsense."
Right?
They can pretend to be talking
about whatever they're talking
about but they're going to
actually send coded messages.
And these letters would be
passed through both the American
and British lines because they
would supposedly have nothing to
do with the war,
because they were from or to a
woman.
Okay.
So part of this whole plan of
espionage is built around the
simple fact that women were
invisible in public life,
so they were very useful agents
of espionage.
It's also interesting to note
that both the Arnolds' chosen
messenger,
Stansbury, and
Stanbury--Stansbury's chosen
messenger to Andre,
both of them were poets,
and in a sense poets were also
people who would not necessarily
be assumed to be centrally
involved with fighting a war.
It could have been quite
natural for American and British
men of letters to chat,
to meet, to correspond.
Cultural bonds--for example an
interest in the art of poetry--
could easily cross political
boundaries,
and Andre himself was a poet of
sorts,
so that too showed something
interesting about society at the
time: this assumption that
common cultural bonds between
American and British men of
letters and literature could be
assumed to be above politics and
war,
above national bonds enough
that it might help them pass
back and forth between American
and British lines.
Okay.
So using this whole string of
people,
this string of poets,
Arnold and the British
negotiated for a time and then
stopped because the British
would not promise to give Arnold
the huge sum of money that he
demanded for his services.
A year later in 1780,
negotiations began again,
this time focused on a specific
demand by the British.
The British specifically asked
Arnold for his help in getting
control of West Point,
and Arnold felt that he could
probably get command of West
Point and then find a way to
deliver it to the British.
And in exchange for this
mission Arnold wanted 30,000
pounds sterling,
which is a vast sum of money at
this time.
I think--sterling to dollar I
can't translate,
but just to give you a sense--I
believe that when the government
gets under way,
George Washington is making a
salary of $25,000 a year and
that's a big blob of money.
I think Secretary of State,
Secretary of the Treasury were
making $5,000 a year maybe.
So 30,000 pounds sterling is a
lot of money.
Plus, he wanted payment of all
of his debts.
So he's not being modest.
But General
Clinton--communicating through
Andre--refused to commit any
money to Arnold until Arnold had
actually accomplished something.
Right?
He doesn't at this point even
have command of West Point.
So at this point with their
plan almost foiled,
things go perhaps one step
worse when George Washington
asks to see Arnold and tries to
reward him.
Right? He still feels bad.
The guy didn't get the
promotion he wanted.
Washington says he's going to
try to reward him by giving him
a better command than West
Point.
Right?
West Point's not really in the
center of the fighting.
Washington basically says,
'You don't really want West
Point.
I'll give you something better
than West Point,' and,
as Washington later recorded,
Arnold had a strange reaction
to this offer.
Quote: "Upon this
information his countenance
changed and he appeared to be
quite fallen;
and, instead of thanking me,
or expressing any pleasure at
the appointment,
never opened his mouth"--
okay, because he--Arnold's
like, 'uh oh,
[laughs]
this is not what I expected.'
Right?
Peggy Arnold when informed in
Philadelphia that Arnold had
been promised a better command
than West Point apparently burst
into hysterics and then after
regaining herself said she was
sobbing because of the danger
that this put her husband in.
Okay.
She's really sobbing because
their plan is about to be
foiled,
but her explanation again sort
of took advantage of stereotypes
about women,
in this case capitalizing on
the assumption that women were
not involved in such things as
military commands;
they would just be worried
about their husbands' welfare.
So that's the excuse she comes
up with,
and we're going to see her
deploy this really successfully
in just a few minutes at the
sort of penultimate moment of
crisis in this whole
controversy.
Ultimately, that offer of
another command for Arnold fell
through and he was given command
of West Point.
And through that whole chain of
letter exchanges it was quickly
established that Arnold and
Andre and Clinton were now ready
to actually do business.
But now at this crucial point
someone had to speak with Arnold
in person to make final
arrangements.
And here we get yet another
example of how important it was
for young men to gain status in
the army--
and actually young men of all
kinds to gain status in the
army--
and how useful the army could
be for promoting your own status
and reputation,
even for people who already had
some social status--
because in this case Andre's
commander in chief and friend,
General Clinton,
said the mission was too
dangerous for his favorite
right-hand man.
Right?
He says to Andre,
'This is not for you.
This is too dangerous,' but
Andre actually insisted on being
the communicator between Clinton
and Arnold because he really
desperately wanted a chance to
earn a promotion and he really
thought that this moment of
potential glory could be it,
could be his big chance.
So Andre and Arnold met;
they talked.
Throughout his trip to meet
with Arnold and during the
visit,
Andre claimed to be a merchant
named John Anderson--
right?--and he wore this sort
of cloak,
but it's important to note that
underneath his cloak he had on
his British uniform.
And this was important because
if he was captured in his
official uniform,
he would be a prisoner of war
and thus protected,
even possibly traded back to
the British in exchange for a
high-ranking American prisoner,
but if he was in plain clothes
he would be a lowly spy,
and a spy had only one fate
waiting for him and that was
death by hanging.
So he's cloaked but he does
have on his British uniform.
Okay.
Complications naturally arose
when a friend of Arnold's saw
Andre with the cloak off.
Right?
So the friend of Arnold says,
'Wow.
You're chatting with a British
officer.
[laughter] What does that mean?'
Okay.
So forced to come up with some
kind of an explanation--you
could imagine that moment;
that's a big sort of "uh
oh,
[laughs]
I'm chatting with a British
officer"--
Arnold said that Andre was a
merchant who had put on a
British uniform to sneak through
British lines.
Right?
Quick thinking on Arnold's
part, but Arnold's friend said:
'Oh, okay.
Well, given that'--he says to
Andre--
'You'd be much safer now just
to dress in plain clothes,
because now that you're past
British lines you shouldn't be
wearing a British uniform.'
Okay.
There's not a lot that Andre
can say to that logic so he puts
on plain clothes.
He's carrying papers from
Arnold about their plot and
shoves them into his boot,
and Andre then set off to head
back to General Clinton,
had just about made his way
back to British-claimed
territory when he was stopped by
three men who questioned him,
searched his clothing,
and eventually found the papers
in his boot.
And the three men brought Andre
to American authorities.
Now, even now Andre thought
that maybe he could claim to be
a secret agent in Arnold's
service.
Right?
He's--Actually,
he's wearing plain clothes and
he has papers from Arnold,
so he's thinking:
'well, there's not actually
anything to link me with the
British at this moment.
I could just be a lowly spy
doing something for Arnold so
maybe I'm still okay.'
However, the officer who he was
taken to became suspicious when
Andre was given clean clothes,
and the ribbon that he removed
from his hair was dusted with
powder.
Okay, the sneaky powder.
What that meant was that he
clearly was a gentleman who
powdered his hair.
He was not a lowly spy.
So whoever this observant
person was,
he saw the ribbon,
he saw that it was dusted with
powder,
and he thought:
'I don't think you're some
pseudo lowly spy person.
I think you must be someone
more important.
Something fishy is going on
here.'
So now, this American officer
sent the captured papers on to
George Washington.
Washington, as luck would have
it, was on his way to West Point
to meet with Benedict Arnold.
[laughter]
Right?
Talk about your sort of lucky
strike.
Right?
So he's riding off,
heading to West Point to meet
with Arnold as a friend,
see how West Point is going,
and now this letter from Andre
is winging its way to Arnold's
headquarters at West Point.
When it became obvious that he
was now being really held
suspect,
Andre confessed who he was,
and he did so at this early
point so that he could reveal
that he wasn't a lowly spy but
actually was a gentleman and an
officer who had been caught.
And to him this really made a
difference.
As he explained to Washington,
he wasn't revealing his true
identity for his own safety and
security.
As he put it,
he wasn't trying to
"rescue himself from an
imputation of having assumed a
mean character for treacherous
purposes or
self-interest"--
so he says, 'I'm not revealing
this because I'm hoping to plead
for my life.'
Rather, he was revealing his
true identity,
quote, "to vindicate my
fame" from any suspicion
that he was a lowly spy.
So basically he's revealing who
he is because he wants to be
recognized as an officer and a
gentleman.
And that letter--also sent on
to the headquarters at West
Point to wait for Washington
when he arrives at West Point.
Boy, Washington's going to have
fun when he arrives at West
Point.
Washington has not yet gotten
to Arnold's house.
He sent two of his aides ahead
to prepare for his arrival.
They were actually eating
breakfast with Benedict Arnold
when letters began to arrive at
headquarters.
Realizing that something bad
was unfolding as one after
another sort of dispatch came in
with these frantic letters that
had to get to Washington,
Arnold ran upstairs.
Washington--Washington's aides
later said he looked oddly
agitated.
He told Peggy that they'd been
caught.
He ran downstairs.
He told Washington that--and
his aides actually,
not Washington.
He's not there yet--he told
Washington's aides that he had
to go prepare for a reception
for Washington,
and fled on horseback.
"Poof," he's gone.
And eventually he was taken
aboard a British ship in the
harbor.
Washington arrived shortly
after this moment,
reads all of these letters and
messages that are waiting for
him,
and at this moment Peggy,
who now knows that things are
really exploding and she's in
big trouble,
erupts into hysterics,
entirely flustering all of the
men present--
because she's at this point
surrounded by men--
right?--her husband's aides,
George Washington,
George Washington's aides.
She erupts into hysterics and
one of Arnold's aides said,
"I heard a shriek to me
and sprang from my bed,
ran upstairs,
and there met the miserable
lady,
raving, distracted ...
with her hair disheveled and
flowing about her neck.
Her morning gown,
with few other clothes,
[laughter]
remained on her,
too few to be seen by a
gentleman of the family,
much less by many
strangers."
Okay, the semi-nude Peggy
Arnold.
"She seized me by the hand
with this, to me distressing,
address, and a wild look,
'Colonel ...
have you ordered my child to be
killed?'"
Okay.
Peggy raving,
'You're going to kill my baby.'
She raved apparently for
several days.
Generally speaking,
she could have sincerely been
distressed.
Right?
Her husband just ran off,
things are in trouble,
Washington's there,
the jig is up,
people know about the plot.
Her seeming insanity,
raving about a murdered baby,
maybe not so sincere,
and Washington's aides were
entirely sucked in to her
distress.
As Alexander Hamilton put it,
and he was really sucked right
in there, "one moment she
raved;
another she melted into tears...
in a manner that would have
pierced insensibility itself....
It was the most affecting scene
I ever was witness to"
[laughter]--that's on the part
of Hamilton.
Okay.
So here again is Peggy using
prevailing assumptions about
women to her advantage.
She's raving.
She's hysterical.
She's talking about her baby.
She's not wearing very much
clothing, [laughter]
apparently.
There were many reasons for the
men who were present not to
suspect that she's actually
involved in the treasonous plot.
So Arnold is fleeing to a
British ship,
Andre is an American prisoner,
and Peggy is being doted on by
half a dozen American officers.
[laughter]
By prolonging her hysteria,
she was playing on what she
knew would be their sense of
gallantry to help her,
and their emotional response to
a distraught woman who's sobbing
and semi-nude.
So eventually she went home to
her family in Philadelphia.
Andre's fate was still up for
grabs.
He assumed that a gentleman and
officer of his rank would never
be accused of being a lowly spy
and he would be exchanged for an
equivalent American officer.
But this was not to be.
But interestingly,
while he was in captivity,
Andre became much more than a
British spy to the American
officers who were holding him
prisoner,
because during his captivity
Washington and his aides spent a
lot of time with him and came to
consider him as the very model
of what a gentleman and an
officer should be.
All of Washington's aides
literally wanted to be Andre.
Some of them actually said that
in writing: 'I wish I were
Andre.
[laughter] He's so gallant.
He's so brave.
He's so--' Yeah.
So Andre really is this ideal.
He's handsome.
He's aristocratically genteel.
He's stoic in the face of
imminent death.
He's willingly sacrificing his
life for his country,
even if that country is England
and not America.
Even Washington was taken with
Andre and called him a gallant
and accomplished officer.
Despite such respect for Andre,
his request to be shot as an
officer and a gentleman rather
than hanged as a spy was denied.
Washington couldn't grant that
request without raising doubts
about Andre's guilt as a spy.
So October 1,1780,
was named as the day of Andre's
execution.
On that day Andre dressed with
extreme care.
He went out of his way to show
his calm fortitude and his
gentility and his dignity in the
face of death.
He was a true British officer
to the last,
because apparently as he walked
to the scaffold he said,
quote, "I am very much
surprised to find your troops
under such good
discipline."
[laughter] Can you imagine?
'I'm about to die.
My, you Americans are quite
disciplined, aren't you?'
[laughter]
Thank you, John Andre.
"And your music is
excellent,"
he added.
[laughter] Thank you very much.
He was supposedly taken aback
for a moment when he saw the
gallows, because up until that
moment he really had been
expecting a firing squad.
He asked if he had to die in
this manner.
Told he would,
he replied in a loud voice,
which was remembered later by
lots of people in their diaries
and in letters,
"I am reconciled to my
fate but not to the mode."
Right?
So the audience was like:
'oh, this is moving.'
[laughter]
When asked if he had last words
he said,
"I have nothing more to
say,
gentleman"--boy,
you better practice last words
in this age--
"I have nothing more to
say, gentleman,
but this: you all bear me
witness that I meet my fate as a
brave man."
At this, the crowd began to
sob, [laughter]
and then the trapdoor was
released and that was the end of
Major John Andre.
Now his death inspired
engravings, songs,
poems, plays for years
afterward.
To many Americans,
he remained a sort of ideal
gentleman and officer,
this noble and sensitive youth,
this sort of romantic hero.
He was beloved by young
American officers who thought he
was this superior,
genteel, sophisticated,
cultured individual in a way
that they didn't necessarily
consider themselves to be.
He somehow seemed better than
them, and to many this was
inextricably tied up with the
fact that he was a British
gentleman, the best of that
breed.
The extreme adoration of Andre
in America shows how Americans
still suffered from a little bit
of an inferiority complex in
relation to the British who
still represented--
at least partly in their
mind--the height of culture and
sophistication.
Even now, in a time of war,
they're responding to Andre in
this way.
Peggy eventually joined her
husband in England,
successfully playing her cards
as a woman throughout to protect
herself from the hatred that
certainly was shown to her
husband.
And Arnold of all of them was
really cursed forever,
eternally hated largely of
course because of his treason,
his betrayal of the American
cause,
but partly in a sense also
because in some ways his actions
were understandable to some
people in America.
He was someone who was
ambitious and tried to raise his
status.
He was someone who spent too
much money, took too many risks
to advance himself.
He was someone who was seduced
by all that the British had to
offer.
In a sense, he was a kind of
everyman gone wrong,
an example of the worst that
was possible in this new
somewhat more egalitarian
American world.
So part of the reason why
Americans hated Arnold with such
passion is that partly they
understood that in some ways,
Arnold was them.
Wow. That was just in time.
Okay.
That is the end of today's
lecture.
We move on in the coming weeks
to war,
to Washington,
to sort of looking at how
things are playing out on the
battlefield,
and then we will work our way
towards Articles of
Confederation and an actual
Constitution by the end of the
semester.
We will make it there.
See you on Thursday.